fantasía
realidad nunca más a dieta
hoy he decidido
que no lo voy a volver a hacer hoy me
voy a ver en el espejo y voy a reconocer
a esa persona que no quiero hacer a esa
persona que todos los días se ve
y no se siente a gusto con ella
pero al mismo tiempo voy a respetarme y
voy a aceptarme tal y cual soy para
encontrar la mejor versión de mí
y correcto nunca más a dieta cuántas de
las personas que estamos hoy aquí ha
intentado hacer una dieta
pero el detalle es que sigue a dieta
o no claro sigue a dieta porque porque
intentamos hacer cosas que saben que
están mal
porque intentamos hacer una elección en
un alimento y sabemos que está mal
porque reconocemos perfectamente y no
podemos definitivamente decir que esto
es igual a esto porque si lo sabemos
porque somos inteligentes porque somos
congruentes
es lo que intentamos ser definitivamente
y todos los días nos han dicho y nos han
tratado de sumergir en una idea que no
es real
esto es igual a esto
todos los días pensamos que sí
y no lo es los alimentos no son
alimentos como no los han enseñado los
alimentos son nutrientes
estos nutrientes no son los mismos que
estos y que ha sucedido lo que hemos
tratado de encontrar la dieta perfecta
buscando simplemente
las calorías
todos sabemos que no son las mismas
calorías los de una pizza que los de una
manzana todos lo sabemos pero saben qué
pasa que tratamos de encontrar la dieta
perfecta sin encontrarnos a nosotros
mismos sin definir que nuestro cuerpo es
integral que necesitamos vernos de una
manera completa
dónde está mi parte emocional
involucrada con la comida
dónde está mi parte física hago o no
hago ejercicio pongo de mi parte para
encontrar ese alimento o no lo hago
es así nos han hecho creer en la
industria que debemos desayunar todos
los días y no solamente eso debemos de
comer 5 6 ó 7 veces o que debemos de
comer cada 3 o 2 horas y que la base de
nuestra alimentación son los cereales
esto solamente es un mensaje de la
industria esto no es real
este es en donde nos han sumergido
en una historia y en una idea que si de
verdad fuera real y fuera la parte
fundamental de la alimentación no
seríamos el primer país con obesidad
nuestros niños no estarían hoy enfermos
y sufriendo de diabetes al solamente
tener 5 años
esa es una grave idea pero la realidad y
lo más triste es que nosotros
sabemos que está bien y que está mal y
seguimos tomando las decisiones erróneas
seguimos pensando y tratando de
encontrar el camino ideal como pueblo
todos estos
todos estos los llamados light los
llamados fat free los llamados llamados
diet lo que se supone que está dentro de
los alimentos saludables no señores
esto no son alimentos saludables estos
son alimentos procesados lo que viene
empacado lo que viene enlatado
esto no son alimentos sabemos nosotros
reconocer un alimento real
claro que lo sabemos somos demasiado
inteligentes a nosotros nadie nos hace
tontos el que nos queramos sumergir es
diferente
el queramos creer otras cosas es
diferente pero por qué porque intentamos
sumergir nuestros sueños sumergir
nuestras emociones y nuestros
sentimientos a través de la comida
y eso es lo que pasa no nos encontramos
en una manera integral y qué pasa
entonces nos sumergimos en una adicción
si si somos adictos y así nos debemos de
reconocer adictos me preocupo por mi
hijo que puede ser un adicto a las
drogas pero no me preocupo porque sea
obeso
me preocupo por mi hijo que tenga una
adicción al alcohol
pero no me preocupo porque tiene un
problema de atención
y ese problema de atención y ese
problema de drogas y ese problema de
adicción los tenemos todos y eso se
llama azúcar
el azúcar es nuestro peor enemigo
y no es parte de nuestra alimentación no
nadie se va a morir si no consume azúcar
hoy hemos estado sumergidos en la gran
historia y en la gran idea de que si no
comemos azúcar
no podemos sobrevivir porque resulta que
el cuerpo lo necesita no es cierto
esta es la gran mentira y la más grande
que hoy tiene sumergida a todo
la humanidad completa
en la enfermedad
el azúcar
nunca pasa dieta porque hoy
he decidido que para festejar un
cumpleaños no tengo que hacer esto
que parece festejar una fiesta y
disfrutar un momento de alegría no tengo
que estar sumergida en esto
quien nos dice que para ser felices
necesitamos el alcohol quien nos dice
que para sobrevivir a una fiesta
necesito estar alcoholizado quien nos
dice que la cerveza ahora es hidratación
perdón
todo el mundo sabe que eso no es cierto
sumerja monos en la realidad en lo que
de verdad verdad quiero ser hoy tomó la
decisión de decidir entre esto y esto y
eso no quiere decir que nunca más voy a
volver
a comer algo dulce o a disfrutar en mi
paladar
algún postre no pero voy a hacer
congruente con lo que deseo con lo que
quiero con la persona que de verdad
verdad se quiere ver en ese espejo y ya
no voy a estar todos los días de mi vida
sufriendo por ver un número de la
báscula
es la realidad
esto que vemos aquí es lo que todos los
días intentamos pensar que un poquito no
está mal
así es es la industria que nos tiene en
noticia 2 que nos tienen engañados pero
señores somos de verdad tan ignorantes
para dejarnos engañar 1 2 3
es como la pareja y en los novios que se
engañan mutuamente y dicen el tercero ya
saliste ya vienen veces
345 veces que te pegaron tendió y ahora
sí
y salir de adelante
cuántas veces voy a durar envenenando mi
cuerpo sabiendo lo que estoy haciendo
sabiendo que hoy cuando me siente a
desayunar me voy a tomar el cereal con
la leche con el jugo de naranja cuando
ya oí la información está en nuestras
manos
sabemos que un jugo de naranja tiene 25
gramos de azúcar lo mismo que tiene una
cocacola sabemos diferenciar azúcar es
azúcar en cualquier presentación que
venga
y lo vemos todos los días
que les que les quiero dejar
les quiero dejar puntos claves somos
inteligentes para distinguir si sí lo
somos a partir de hoy nunca más a dieta
porque voy a saber que entre a mi boca y
voy a tomar la decisión de que quiero y
no quiero
voy a leer las etiquetas si así tengo
que iniciar no es lo mismo leer esto que
leer esto
si todavía sigo en el mercadeo de
productos industrializados hay buenas
opciones y si las hay pero debemos de
leer debemos de instruir nos debemos de
saber al 100% qué es lo que estamos
comiendo y si no no tienes a hacer por
ti no importa hazlo por tu familia hazlo
por tus hijos
hazlo por aquella persona a la que le
quieres dejar un mensaje
[Música]
nunca más a dieta porque la báscula no
me interesa nosotros no somos un número
de báscula nosotros somos una persona de
carne y hueso
nada nos limita
a tomar buenas decisiones porque hoy
somos inteligentes somos congruentes
somos personas que sabemos tomar una
elección siempre lo hemos sabido sabemos
perfectamente si cruzar la calle cuando
pasa un carro o esperar y voltear a los
lados
por qué no hacerlo cuando la decisión
más importante de tu vida es tu salud
hoy es la decisión más importante hoy
definitivamente voy a comer por la
intuición ese es mi mensaje cuando tenga
hambre voy a comer cuando no tenga
hambre no voy a comer
olvidemos este mensaje de comer todos
los días 5 y 6 veces al día y cada 3
horas porque es que el metabolismo se va
a parar no es cierto eso
eso es un mensaje de la industria y
lamentablemente no solamente la
industria sino
todo el círculo que engloba la educación
es increíble y es muy triste ver hoy
instituciones educativas con mucho
reconocimiento enviando mensajes a la
población que ya con todas las líneas de
información que tenemos hoy nos quieran
seguir engañando
muy muy feo y eso es a quién a donde
nosotros estamos sumergidos hoy por eso
no nos podemos dejar engañar no somos un
número de la báscula somos una población
entera
que lo que vamos a hacer es comunidad lo
que vamos a hacer es enviar el mensaje
al de al lado pero para eso soy
congruente para eso yo soy la primera
persona que va a elevar el mensaje si yo
pretendo que mis hijos sean saludables
en mi casa yo seré la primera saludable
y esto no quiere decir que vamos a que
nos vamos a obsesionar no al contrario
el mensaje que les tengo hoy es que no
se obsesione no se obsesionen con
cualquier tipo de dieta no se obsesionen
por contar carbohidratos o calorías
simplemente coman comida real porque
somos inteligentes porque somos
congruentes porque tenemos mucha
información hoy y porque nadie de los
que está aquí somos ignorantes
escojamos lo que sabemos que realmente
es saludable y seamos felices y libres
gracias
[Aplausos]